hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll so the Internet you may have
heard of it kind of a big deal good
chance that you're either listening to
this podcast over the internet or
somehow used the internet to find out
about this podcast or to download it or
whatever it's still a state of flux when
it comes to how society deals with not
just the internet but technology more
generally computers smartphones things
like that and one of our sharpest
thinkers about this relationship between
humanity and the changing world of
technology is today's guest Cory
Doctorow Cory is best known perhaps as
the co-editor of the blog boeing-boeing
but he's also a science fiction writer
his most recent book is called
radicalize a collection of four novellas
but he's also a very prolific nonfiction
writer and he thinks deeply not just
about technology but about the law
philosophy morality the economics of it
all so we really get into the
relationship that people have not only
with technology but with the
corporation's the powers that bring this
technology to us and the ways that they
are leveraging our interest to make
money for themselves and the good parts
and bad parts of that and how we can
sort of fight against it Cory talks
about these things both in his essays
and books but also his stories which
gives him a number of different angles
on these important problems so it's a
very fast multifaceted
idea rich conversation I think you're
going to like it remember that you can
visit the podcast homepage at
preposterous universe com and if you're
interested in listening to mindscape
without ads you can become a patreon
which is linked from the podcast page
patrons also get monthly ask me anything
episodes you can ask me a question I'll
do my best to answer it of course
regular old episodes always available
here for free whenever you want them so
let's go
[Music]
Cory Doctorow thanks so much for being
on podcast it's my pleasure thank you
for having me
you've been around the internet a long
time I mean I don't know since the very
earliest days or at least since before
we knew it as the Internet sure I mean I
think my first point of contact was with
their early networks across universities
in the 70s when my dad started bringing
home teletype terminals from the
University of Toronto and then on BBS is
that were connected to fidonet and
through that to Usenet okay so not as
early as like people who helped with the
TCP transition for ARPANET but pretty
early so here's an ambitious question to
start us off then we're clearly not in
equilibrium right the Internet and the
way that we use it is changing rapidly
do you see us approaching a future
internet equilibrium even if you can't
excite exactly what it is can you
imagine various forms of steady states
that we will eventually reach in terms
of how we use the internet how it
affects our lives stuff like that
I think there's actually a risk of that
I would not call that a good outcome you
know as as other people have observed
that the web has become five giant
websites filled with screenshots from
the other four yeah
and that domination of the web by a
small number of firms that continues to
shrink and who clearly carve out
competitive niches for one another an
occasionally compete with each other but
mostly our content to just sort of sit
pat that has been I think a net negative
for the internet and for human thriving
and for things like human rights and and
I fear that the path to that becoming
permanent is that regulators will
observe the dysfunction of a highly
concentrated internet for example a
single social platform with 2.3 billion
people on it whose choices about
algorithmic filtering and recommendation
drive all kinds of negative outcomes
including you know people who understand
it again the system to livestream mass
shootings in Christchurch yeah and that
they'll say to these firms since we
can't imagine any way to make you
smaller and therefore
make your bad decisions less
consequential we will instead insist
that you take measures that would
traditionally be in the domain of the
state like policing bad speech and bad
actions and those measures will be so
expensive that they will preclude any
new entrance to the market so whatever
anti-competitive environment we have now
will become permanent and I call it the
constitutional monarchy right it's it's
where instead of hoping that we could
have a technological democracy where you
have small holders who individually
pitch their little corner of the web and
maybe Fedder a twith one another to
build bigger systems but that are
ultimately you know power is devolved to
the periphery instead what we what we
say is that current winners of the
technological lottery actually rule with
the Divine Right of Kings and they they
will be our rulers forever but in
exchange for that they will suffer
themselves to be draped in golden chains
by an aristocracy of regulators who are
ultimately going to be drawn from their
upper echelon it's because you know when
you only have five companies in an
industry the only people who understand
them well enough to regulate them are
their executives and so you end up with
just a revolving door
so the aristocracy will well call upon
the tech giants to exercise a kind of
noblesse oblige a where they will they
will suffer themselves to make certain
concessions to the public interest at
the expense of their shareholders but in
exchange they will be guaranteed a
regulatory environment that precludes
anyone ever challenging them and I think
that will be studied but not for long
because I also think that if we think
that Google and Facebook are
intransigent today if we give them a
decade without even having to buy
potential competitors to prevent them
from growing to challenge them imagine
how bully-ish and terrible they'll be in
ten years so there was a little bit of a
leap there that I'd like to dig into
more certainly there's this move for the
government or the people asking places
like Google and Facebook to police
themselves a little bit better right -
police speech on their platforms etc
Twitter but then so if we're making that
ask you seem to be implying that that's
actually secretly giving some power to
them that should maintain for ourselves
I mean Mark Zuckerberg said it himself
ready he went up and he said please
regulate Facebook right like please
throw me in that briar patch because
Zuckerberg knows that any regulation
that is made to curb the worst parts of
Facebook will not include as a potential
remedy getting rid of Facebook right it
they what Facebook and Google perceive
and and the other big tech companies
including Apple there's an opportunity
to becoming de facto state monopolies
comparable to say 80 during the heyday
of the bail system so there was a long
time when the bell systems dysfunctions
were very obvious right the company had
engaged in so much anti-competitive
behavior that was ultimately bad for
innovation and bad for individual
liberty and the liberty of groups and
the ability of people to coordinate
among themselves and access to to
telecommunications infrastructure in
rural places and so on
and and yet no one had the appetite to
break up 18 t because whenever it was
proposed 18 t would say well we have
been mandated to become a part of the
nation's public safety and security
right come disasters come crises we are
asked to be a kind of quasi governmental
entity we need the monopoly profits that
we get from our abusive practices from
expensive long distance from insisting
that everyone rent their phones month on
month until they paid for them a hundred
times over from being able to decide who
can plug what into the system so that we
can keep people from having answering
machines unless they come from us and so
on
we need those windfall profits to pay
for those state like duties and it took
you know arguably like 30 years longer
than it should have to break up AT&T and
unfortunately arrived at the tail end of
the antitrust movement you know 1982 we
finally break them up just as Reagan is
dismantling antitrust so immediately
what they do is reconverge
right you know so that we end up with
with not one telco but three and they're
all terrible anyone was a cellphone
knows that they're pretty terrible and
all run by former eighteen two
executives yeah right you know they're
all spin-offs of AT&T run by former
eighteen two executives it's you know
it's like the Pope dividing up the new
world right like it's nice that the
Portuguese and the Spaniards didn't have
to fight over it but I'm sure the people
they subjugated weren't
coppy Ariel and Caliban who are the
feline mascots of the mindscape podcast
wanted me to let you know how much
they're enjoying pretty litter their new
kind of cat litter basically pretty
litter is really good at everything that
kitty litter is supposed to be good at
it's made of these absorbent crystals
that are really good at odor protection
they trap and conceal the odor and the
moisture it's a very clean kind of
situation that you have it's very
convenient because they deliver the
pretty litter to your door one little
bag which is not that heavy will last
for one cat for one month and perhaps
best of all there's this science going
on inside pretty litter which monitors
your cat's health if the cat is getting
some illness some sort of sickness for
which urgent medical care might be
needed the pretty litter will change
color to let you know so do what I did
and make the switch to pretty litter
today by visiting pretty litter comm and
using promo code mindscape for 20% off
your first order
that's pretty litter comm promo code
mindscape for 20% off and do you think
that the pleasant situation with
facebook and google and amazon having so
much of their respective market shares
wouldn't have been possible in the
previous antitrust regulation I mean you
look at Google Google's a company that
only ever made one and a half products
right they made a really good search
engine and a pretty good hotmail clone
and then everything else they do is a
company they bought and it's a company
that they wouldn't have been permitted
to buy pre reagan right and it wasn't
just reagan reagan kicked it off but
every successive administration has
reified and expanded reagan's antitrust
malpractice up to and including obama
and certainly trump is supercharged at
green-lighting absurd mergers like
t-mobile Sprint you know that but the
these the the the pre Reagan era had a
pretty widespread prohibition on merging
with major competitors acquiring
potential future competitors as they
were getting started or cornering
vertical markets and if you look at
Apple Google Facebook Microsoft that's
all they've ever done right it's all
there you know yeah who's the poster
child for this right and and yahoo is
the poster child for what the terminal
condition of it is or one of the
terminal conditions what
is that you can raise a ton of capital
in the markets then you can buy up and
destroy every promising tech startup for
25 years cash your investors out several
times over and still end up with nothing
to show for it that's actually like the
best case scenario because then the
company and be so bad at it right that
the the worst case scenario is they do
all of that but continue in a
steady-state right back to your question
about steady states is that you end up
with a permanent Facebook that just goes
out and aqua hires every promising
technology company destroys anything
good about what they were making takes
the parts that can be used to enhance
its monopoly and rent-seeking activity
and integrates them into its product
lines and we end up with you know a
series of nested walled gardens which is
what we have now like last year Facebook
lost the largest number of American
users and its history it lost 13 million
13 to 13 million 13 to 30 four year olds
left Facebook last year but the majority
of them ended up on Instagram which is a
Facebook subsidiary yes right you know
there it is you can imagine this just
going on forever right you know walled
gardens within walled gardens where you
escaped one and only to end up in the
next one over so what would you like an
equilibrium to be if you had to put up
with an equilibrium so I would like for
there to be a stable set of what for one
of better terms we might call
constitutional principles for Federation
so if you think about US federalism as
maybe an example and it's obviously not
without its dysfunctions see the
electoral college and so on that what we
have are individual autonomous small
regulatory units in the form of states
or mid-sized regulatory units in the
form of states sometimes they get very
big we're sitting here in California but
but smaller than the nation and then we
have a set of governing principles that
dictate with the minimum set of personal
freedoms those regulators have to give
to the people who are under there and
within their remit and first among them
is the freedom to go somewhere else
right and if you could imagine that we
would have a set of rules about
you know distributing malicious software
denial service attacks certain kinds of
in sentence to incitements to violence
and and discriminatory conduct related
to protected categories of identity
including you know race and and gender
and so on and that people who agree to
adhere to those federated greed to
adhere to those but what they do within
that Federation is incredibly variable
so you know I know a woman a friend of
mine who writes comic books and her
comic books are really cool really smart
on gender you know kind of feminist
inflected superhero comics for
mainstream comics publishers and she is
the target of harassment by a small
group of really terrible men on Twitter
who have a method for gaming Twitter's
anti-harassment policies and what they
do is they send you just revolting
threatening direct messages which they
delete as soon as you read them because
Twitter won't accept screenshots cuz
they're too easy to dr. and Twitter to
its credit when you actually delete
something Twitter can't readily access
it it's pretty much deleted I mean maybe
there's a backup somewhere but you can't
say to Twitter go find that DM that was
in my in my messages you know two hours
ago
cuz it's gone they can't see it which is
good what you want that you want if you
and your group of Hong Kong protesters
are planning a protest but you don't
want the Politburo to be able to order
you'll be able to delete things that
should be a right yeah deletions good
so although if I receive a DM maybe I
should be able to keep a copy of it what
if you've been arrested by the Chinese
state and you want and the person who
sent you the message wants to delete the
incriminating side of it I mean yeah
ideally I should be able to delete it
but maybe the Chinese police wouldn't
let me do that yeah that's that's fair
yeah so so you know you get arrested
your phone is now in the hands of the
Hong Kong security services I have sent
you are privy to a threat of messages
that expose 50 organizers that you work
with they delete the messages you want
it to disappear from your phone's
different threat models in different use
case
and actually we're going to come to that
in terms of in terms of what could be
done so then these men what they do is
they send messages in your public
Twitter stream that reference this
threatening message but without the
threatening message is a key they do not
seem threatening in and of themselves
and so what they can do is continually
harass you but without ever giving rise
to an offense that would have them
kicked off Twitter
now imagine that Twitter could not avail
itself of any legal tools to prevent a
third party for making an interoperable
Twitter service right a rival to Twitter
like a mastered on instance that you
could use to both read and write Twitter
and my friend and her dozen friends were
targeted by these hundred men could make
a Twitter alike that they could use to
be part of the public discourse that
takes place on Twitter but that would
have a rule that all of these shitty men
were blocked and that would allow you to
recover DMS for the purposes of dealing
with this this kind of harassment and so
on you could now have a broad set of
broad latitude within a decentralized
local means of communicating with
everybody else that would allow people
who were targeted for harassment to deal
with this one-in-a-million use case
right remember Facebook's got 2.3
billion users that means they've got
2,300 one in a million use cases every
day so it would allow you to deal with
this one in a million use case that is
inconceivable that big firms would be
able to deal with even if they had the
political will which they don't and and
you could still on that periphery be
part of this larger conversation you
wouldn't have to opt out of being in the
world just to be protected from
grotesque harassment right that would
allow you to have a use case in what you
say I want the evidentiary Twitter where
DMS are not deleted right I want to be
able to to retain them even if my
counterparty doesn't and you could you
could opt in to being on that Twitter
and Twitter wouldn't have you wouldn't
have to wait for Twitter to adjudicate
your case to decide that that's what you
want so imagine there's like 20
different clones of Twitter each with
different rules and also
interoperability yeah
whatever future utopia so that you would
have not just interoperability through
standardization which you might call
voluntary interoperability and not just
enter offer
ability through indifference which you
might call indifferent and
interoperability you know the people who
make your car don't care what you plug
into the cigarette lighter Apple really
wants everyone who makes an app to
follow a set of interoperable terms so
they've got they've got voluntary
interoperability or enthusiastic
interoperability your car manufacturers
got in different interoperability those
are both good and really important
standards fall into that category and so
on I'm talking about adversarial
interoperability right that's when I
plug something in that you really don't
want plugged in because it helps me
improve my life or the life of my
customers or users right and so that
would be like third-party printer ink so
imagine if Twitter could avail itself of
technical countermeasures to try to
block people who scrape they're waiting
Twitter messages and move them into a
Twitter alike service with their own
rules but they couldn't sue over patent
infringement they couldn't sue for
violating Terms of Service they couldn't
Vasu under the Digital Millennium
Copyright Act and it's prohibition on
circumvention they couldn't bring a
tortious interference claim that you
would have blanket immunity for all
legal theories for any activity that
creates interoperability that allows
users to have more control over the
technologies that they use and it get
the impression that this is not what
these companies want I mean Facebook
used to allow me to just forward my
tweets and post them on Facebook but
they cut off that ability I presume it's
because they don't want too much
interoperability well I mean Facebook
went further than that Facebook when it
launched had a tool that would log into
myspace pretend to be you use your login
and password get your waiting myspace
messages put them in your facebook inbox
and let you reply to them
right because that's how they solve the
collective-action problem of well
Facebook is better than MySpace but my
friends are on MySpace I can't leave
myspace until my friends are on Facebook
they won't leave myspace until I'm on
Facebook we're all stuck here within
MySpace
they just let you have one foot on
either side of the walled garden right
now Facebook having done that sued a
competitor called power ventures that
made exactly the same tool that would
allow you to read your facebook messages
and your LinkedIn messages and your
Twitter messages all within one
interface and get you away from Facebook
being able to observe everything you do
spy on you while you're doing it and
then you know use that information to
target ads and what was the grounds for
the lawsuit it's the Computer Fraud and
Abuse Act so the Computer Fraud and
Abuse Act was passed in nineteen
sex after Ronald Reagan watched the
movie wargames and panicked the federal
prosecutors have been champing at the
bit to have a more expansive definition
of cybercrime and hacking they arrived
at a definition that was so expensive
that its effectual effectively without
limits they said that anytime you exceed
your authorization on a system that does
not belong to you that you potentially
commit a felony right now that sounds
like a reasonable thing on its face you
know if you work at the video store and
your boss gives you the right to check
in and out videos but doesn't give you
the right to go back and like get the
home addresses of cute customers and go
stalk them at home then you know you've
exceeded your authorization
but today authorization is Terms of
Service right it's that sprawling
novella of garbage release that no one's
ever read and it boils down to like by
being dumb enough to use this service
you agree that we're allowed to come
over to your house and punch your
grandmother and wear your underwear and
make long-distance calls right and so
Facebook argued that power ventures had
violated its Terms of Service and in so
doing had violated the Computer Fraud
and Abuse Act they built on a decision
that Blizzard had gotten that the world
of warcraft' people over an
interoperable game server called bina D
now that law is being eroded or that
that precedent is being eroded LinkedIn
just lost a court challenge against a
competitor called high Q that scrapes
LinkedIn publicly available LinkedIn
data to create analytics for employers
and that was fine with LinkedIn for a
while and then LinkedIn launched its own
analytics analytics product and shut
down high Q and and sued them and the
court not only found that high Q was not
violating the Computer Fraud and Abuse
Act they actually ordered LinkedIn to
not take technical countermeasures to
shut down high Q to allow high Q to
continue to scrape the service so you
know that legal theory that exotic legal
theory which was very expensive and
hard-won for Facebook chilled a
generation of technologists right you
know this is why venture capitalists
call Facebook's business which grows
year-on-year by double digits and is
generating billions of dollars in
profits they call that the kill zone
right under normal market conditions you
would expect that if you had
double-digit year-on-year growth for a
multi-billion dollar business that
people would be very excited about
figuring out how to take your 1,000%
margin and offer the same service at a
five hundred percent margin but no right
they they that Facebook stands alone
no one will fund you to compete with
Facebook the last company that really
tried in earnest was snap and Facebook
used an acquisition of there's an
acquisition that would have been illegal
prior to Reagan a company called inaho
that made a deceptive battery monitor
that actually monitored everything you
did on your phone and sent that
telemetry to Facebook to discover that
Facebook's users were downloading and
installing snap and to then gather in
fine detail how snap was being used and
Facebook used that to both buy and tweak
Instagram to become a direct snap
competitor right I'm trying to think if
I had this battery monitor when was this
happening it was about seven years ago
okay Oh novel then morphed into a
surveilling VPN which is like the most
ironic piece of product but it's a VPN
that keeps what you do private from your
ISP but spas and everything you do and
sends it to Facebook so there's examples
of adversarial interoperability just
because the company really if I to do it
like Apple made software where you could
read Microsoft Word documents but you
seem to be suggesting that there's also
legal issues here that I mean is it true
that a facebook just tried hard enough
on the tech side they could prevent this
kind of interoperability well I mean
that's I think I think that Facebook
would say they would say you don't need
to take away our legal defenses we have
a monopoly on the smartest technologists
and so we will always win but that's not
what they did right they didn't just
shut down power ventures they see the
power ventures right it's not like
lawyers are cheaper than programmers
right I mean maybe they just wanted to
make an example but I'm inclined to
think that the legal issues are the real
chilling effect you know it's a truism
in information security that defenders
have a harder job than attackers right
if you are building a wall around your
castle that wall needs to be perfect if
I want to knock it down I need to find
one mistake you've made right and so
that asymmetry makes life very very hard
for defenders and you know the fact that
Facebook is supporting 2,300
one-in-a-million use cases every day
means that detecting BOTS and
distinguishing them from users who are
just doing things that are weird is very
hard right that the total scope of what
passes for normal user activity among
Facebook's 2.3 billion user pool is so
broad yeah that there's just plenty of
latitude to make scrapers that that look
like a user somewhere I wonder if a lot
of people on the legal side have this
the example in mind of Internet Explorer
where it was thought to be a monopoly
and there were a lot of legal rama new
vers to sort of break up that monopoly
but in retrospect it kind of wasn't
because it was very easy to replace it
with someone else do a lot of people
think that Facebook will just be
replaced organically by better
competition or is this truly a different
situation so it's an interesting
question about what happened with
Explorer Explorer was at the heart of an
antitrust lawsuit that ultimately did
not succeed but Microsoft insiders say
that what happened through the antitrust
enforcement action was that it changed
the internal calculus inside the
boardroom said Microsoft that Microsoft
like every other big institution has a
spectrum of attitudes and ideas about
products and the best way to launch them
into the market but historically people
who said we should do things that would
be illegal under antitrust law always
won the argument because every time
Microsoft did that they gained market
share and then you have the antitrust
action and the antitrust action against
Microsoft is really interesting because
it was the first one where the
depositions were a video recorded and
released to the public and Bill Gates
when he was deposed lost it so you know
he is clearly he's on the spectrum and
his spectrum behaviors became very very
obvious during that deposition in a way
that we had not seen in Bill Gates
public appearances he starts Rocking
he starts stimming and then you know
when he's talking to them he's very
belligerent and very unsympathetic right
and there is a story from Microsoft
insiders that says that after that every
time anyone proposed doing something
really terrible someone in the boardroom
would say don't make them put bill back
on the stand right
it is often cred
with the growth of Google right how did
Google manage to avoid the kind of
anti-competitive behavior the Microsoft
was happy to engage in with every other
competitor well you know might have been
that they were stayed by you know what
you might call the the policeman inside
right the internalized belief that if
you did this that you would face
terrible consequences certainly that
seems to have been the case with IBM so
in in 81 or 82 and when IBM was creating
the first pcs its first pcs they did a
bunch of things that were uncommon for
IBM so one was that they used commodity
components and this is a company that
had been known to make its own machine
screws that were proprietary for their
mainframes they also did not sue Phoenix
the company that reverse engineered
their roms and re-implemented them so
that Compaq and every other PC
manufacturer can make PC clones
now that year was also the year that the
DOJ was finally stepping back from a
12-year antitrust enforcement action
against them over mainframes that only
ended because mainframes ceased to be a
line of business for IBM it's getting
them for antitrust over mainframes to be
like you know have that monopoly go
ahead yeah yeah you're gutta-percha
monopoly is safe right yeah and and
again there are lots of people who say
that the reason that IBM did these
extraordinary things is that the people
in the boardroom who had historically
said let's not use bullying tactic and
set against our competitors let's use
commodity components because it allows
us to iterate faster and even though we
don't control the whole supply chain we
can do more that those people started to
win the arguments after 12 years of
being batted around up and down the the
you know 12 miles of dirt road by the by
the DOJ finally you know they were
starting to win the arguments I want to
pause for a second to talk about joy
Bird furniture in this day and age we
live in a customizable society you can
pick and choose what you want get it
delivered to your home and furniture
should catch up to that that's what joy
bird is doing they basically offer you
the options of making your own design
for the furniture with over 50 options
for leather and fabric three different
shades of wood and over 250 unique
silhouettes
you can do the math that's over 37,000
different kinds of pieces of furniture
that you can get so you can basically
design furniture that matches your own
personal style for your home or your
apartment and the best thing is if you
don't like it you can return it there's
a 365 day home trial so rather than
going to a showroom and picking over
things that just happen to be there
you can design what you want online have
it delivered and then see how it fits so
you can create furniture that matches
your own style at joy Byrd comm slash
mindscape that's joy bird comm slash
mindscape and you can receive an
exclusive offer for 25% off your first
order when you use that code mindscape
so design your personal pad today is it
is there a problem that people seem to
maybe like living in walled gardens or
even they like sort of handing over some
of their property their rights to use
their own property to these major
corporations like you know with phones
and TV services and so forth so if that
were the case we wouldn't need
countermeasures right if people loved
paying extra for ink because they knew
it was reliable then printer
manufacturers wouldn't have to take all
those countermeasures to prevent third
party ink and if people loved the
convenience of letting Apple decide
which apps they could use they could use
then Apple wouldn't need to take so many
countermeasures to prevent third party
app stores the reality is that locking
users in creates a kind of moral hazard
right it takes all the things that are
good about your product that your
customers actually like like the
reliability of your ink or the fact that
the apps are vetted and of high quality
and invites you to abuse that trust
because you know that if you abuse the
trust once they've kind of wandered into
the walled garden that there's no way
for them to use markets to punish you
right and so that you see the monotonic
ratcheting up of printer ink and of
incredibly restrictive terms over
printers so you know HP now makes
printers where you only rent the ink and
so you subscribe really you yeah you
subscribe to a certain number of pages
per month and it doesn't matter how much
ink is in your printer if you've
exceeded your page budget your printer
won't print right Hasbro just did this
with its new nerf gun they have a nerf
gun that
won't fire third-party darts and it uses
technical countermeasures to prevent you
from firing through party darts if
people loved Hasbro's darts those
countermeasures would be superfluous I
think of the k-cup coffee makers have
been testing shirts right you buy the
machine but then you're on hook for the
rest of your life do you have little
cups yeah and you know if it's true that
that's what people want you wouldn't
need a patent and you wouldn't need
copyright enforcement you wouldn't need
Terms of Service you you could just rely
on your customers incredible adoration
for your product but people do seem to
like Facebook right or at least you know
multi-million people left it last year
yes Facebook has at least as many
hostages as it has users yeah right um
you know again like I think that they're
by the way I'm this is totally me being
devil's advocate I basically left
Facebook as I find a repellent but I
don't use any Facebook products you know
I think that um Facebook does have this
incredible advantage that is separate
from its monopoly advantage which is the
network effect right I am skeptical of
network effects is the kind of central
explanation for how we ended up with
these monopolies but the network effect
of like everyone in your kids little
league team is using Facebook to
organize games means that you either
take your kid at a little league or you
get a Facebook account that clearly
works to Facebook's favor the monopoly
part is that it's not hard to imagine a
third-party service that would allow you
to monitor the things going on with the
Little League game while not having to
have a Facebook account Facebook it's
very interesting in the wake of
Cambridge analytic uh has used the moral
panic over Cambridge analytic to
militate against any service that would
allow you to do that because they say
well if you can monitor the Little
League game maybe you could evade our
anti harassment or anti data mining or
anti political manipulation tools you
should and in fact Zuckerberg in these
leaked audio recordings that that word
just came out this week is we're
recording this from his internal
meetings he says that Elizabeth Warren
is misguided in wanting to break up
Facebook because only someone with
kind of resources that Facebook has
could prevent political manipulation
right I mean it's a benevolent
dictatorship well and it's hilarious
that that Zuckerberg answer to his
catastrophic failure to prevent
political manipulation is to entrust him
and deputize him to prevent political
manipulation and talk about fool me
twice shame on me and I love the
prevalence these days of when you're
trying to sign up for new service they
give you the option of logging in with
Google or logging in with Facebook and I
think that I was trying to do one just
the other day that those are the only
two options like I couldn't create an
account on this service and that just
seems to be handing myself over to these
Bing companies but I mean this is why I
keep pressing on this because the
convenience of it must be attractive to
a large fraction of people you know if
there's others who don't like it you
know just live on Facebook and let
Facebook handle everything yeah but
there's there's I think you've got um an
or where you want an ant right
you could have Facebook manage all your
login yes and you could have the ability
to take all that stuff outside of
Facebook and put it somewhere else if
you decided that Facebook wasn't a good
steward of your of your stuff and if
that were the case right if Facebook
could not prevent that then they would
be incentivized to be more respectful of
your privacy and your attention and your
data right that that as our conservative
friends like to remind us incentives
matter right Facebook has no incentive
to treat you with dignity because they
know that you're stuck it's like that
old Lily Tomlin sketch about the phone
company right we don't have to care
we're the phone company right Facebook
doesn't have to care even if you leave
Facebook you will become an Instagram
user
why would Facebook ever care and it
sounds like the only way to really have
change here is through legal means or I
mean it's not going to be small actions
by groups of users complaining right so
I I think that a Larry Lessig's
framework for change really works here
that that the four drivers of change are
code what's technologically possible law
what's lawfully permissible norms with
socially acceptable and markets what's
profitable and clearly competing with
Facebook could be profitable right that
Norton under normal circumstances
markets would actually go along
correcting the worst excesses of
facebook but there are legal impediments
to those those Corrections now the fact
that there are businesses like Snap that
are really pissed off of Facebook and
like Yelp that are really pissed off at
Google over their anti-competitive
behavior means that there is a
commercial constituency to push for
legal reform so it's not just consumer
rights groups that are doing this now I
don't think that Snap or Yelp are going
to be any better stewards of their power
than Facebook is I'm not a tech
Exceptionalist right I don't think that
tech executives are either so virtuous
that they can't be regulated or
shouldn't be regulated or so venal that
they that they will always be wicked I
think that they are everyday sociopaths
and incentives matter and if you let
them get away with murder then they'll
have blood on their hands right so I
think that although we have these
commercial constituencies that will
militate for legal reform that are the
eyes on the prize should be about a much
more pluralistic world where you have
lots and lots of people doing it and
that's where things like technology come
in right because one of the things that
we know is that whole products can be
replaced with small scripts right that
that a lot of times users have taken
something that started off as like
something a network administrator would
do to automate their most boring parts
of their job and just turn it into a
thing that they do all day long that
just just make stuff happen right and so
users give an access to easy technology
that tools myths can make that the laws
don't threaten that people have an
understanding of the need for because
they've had a normative shift that that
we can affect gross changes in user
behavior the risk is to just put this
all down to individual choice right it's
it's the same as with climate change
right that that the reason we have
climate change is not because of your
lack of recycling diligence and the
reason we have Facebook is not because
you individually didn't choose to leave
Facebook that these these big social
factors that are at play are are what
has created this dominance for Facebook
it's what's created the social crisis
the climate crisis and averting it
does require individual action but that
individual action is to join groups yeah
and to use those groups to affect social
scale change right that you know it's
not gonna happen in your blue box it's
gonna happen at your city hall meeting
at the ballot box in the streets that's
where the change is gonna come from and
you've written about this stuff in
numerous venues and genres and one of
them I need to mention is science
fiction and you have a new book out
called radicalised and my favorite story
and it was what was it unauthorized
bread an authorized bread i'm the
authorized bread which deals directly
with this idea of the company having the
right to let you do things why don't you
tell us a little bit yeah unauthorized
bread it's a story about people in
refugee housing that has been created as
part of a variance to a prop developer a
property developer who wanted to build a
luxury building and wanted planning
permission to add extra stories to it
over the limit and they said yes you can
but some of those stories have to be
subsidized they have to be below market
rent and this happens all the time and
just as with those buildings there's a
port or a different Lobby certainly here
in LA we add new york london all over
the place so you don't go through the
marble lobby with the doorman you go
with literally around the back where the
garbage cans are but they go further the
elevators won't stop for them unless
there's no one from the above market
rent side of the market rent side that
that wants to use it and then every
appliance in the in the poor floors is
designed to extract revenue from those
people that dishwasher only washes
authorized dishes and the laundry
machines only wash authorized clothes
and the toaster is only toast authorized
bread and this is this extractive
program that we see already and in lots
of place it's not that much of an issue
eppley yeah the poorer you are the worse
the technology treats you from subprime
credit card you have which has been
tuned with algorithms to maximize the
amount of penalties that you end up
paying all the way down to your
subsidized cell phone which will cost
you more and come with more shovelware
and spyware than the full market phone
that you buy it's it's not always true
that if you're not paying for the
product you're the product you can also
be the product you're
for it but you're more of the product if
you're not paying for the product and
this is bad enough but then the kinds of
hedge funds that like to back this kind
of business are also the kinds of
financial engineers who periodically
take their business through a bracing
structural bankruptcy for the purpose of
shedding debt and restructuring and that
means that all the server's stopped
working one day and that means the
appliances don't work and this
incentivizes that protagonist the
stories Libyan refugee named Salima to
look up how to Jailbreak her appliances
and the experience is so fulfilling so
that she can toast her brother she can
toaster bread but then because it feels
good right because seizing the means of
computation just feels right she teaches
other people how to do it and it's kind
of sweeps the building like wildfire and
the story takes a turn when these
companies start to restructure to
bankruptcy and thanks to the digital
name Copyright Act and section 1201 of
it which makes it a felony to bypass
copyright locks they're now all facing
felony prosecution and if you're a
refugee that can mean losing your
refugee status and that can mean death
and so it suddenly the stakes go from
which bread can i toast in my toaster to
life or death and how do you find the
sort of effectiveness both sort of in
getting the message out but also just
for your personal pleasure in writing
that in the science-fiction vein versus
just a straightforward article or book
well you know I do both yeah and right
yeah and both are necessary but I have a
theory of change I call peak
indifference okay which is that when you
have a real problem but where that
problems cause and effect are separated
by a lot of time in space sometimes it's
hard to know whether there is a real
problem or what you should do about it
you know whether that's smoking and
cancer or climate change or or making
bad technological decisions and if you
neglect that problem then over time it
will create mounting debt right you'll
get sicker from the cigarettes that your
house will burn down or be flooded out
your technology will start to abuse you
and more grotesque and gratuitous ways
and so after a while the job of an
activist moves from convincing people
that there is a problem to convincing
them that it's not too late to do
something about it
because denialism can slide into
nihilism in just a hot second right you
know you can go from like ah you know
I'm sure the rhinos will be fine too
like all right there's only one of them
left but since there's only one left we
might as well find out what he tastes
like and that's right now for climate
change sure that's exactly what we're
hearing
absolutely same people who said there
never was a problem said you can't never
now saying you can't possibly solve the
problem or or you know on the right you
have the rise of eco fascism which you
know is an ideology espoused by the
Christchurch killer who says oh no
climate change Israel that means that we
have to get rid of half the human race
and it should be the brown people right
and and and you know that's a surprise
it's an old ideology right hardened they
who wrote the tragedy of the Commons was
an eco fascist and you know the Sierra
Club's early founders were dabbled in
eco fascism and and so on but it's come
roaring back it's become a major motif
in our in our society right now
especially among the far-right so the
thing about peak indifference is that
the sooner you can reach that moment the
sooner you can reach the moment where a
critical mass of people acknowledge the
existence of the problem the easier it
is to avert nihilism because the more
wiggle room you have to take action to
improve things right the less debt
policy debt you've incurred and the less
obvious policy bankruptcy seems you know
the less inevitable the policy
bankruptcy scenes and fiction is a
really good way to make people vividly
imagine the consequences of long off
activities nonfiction can do it I mean
the Silent Spring is obviously like an
example that often gets cited but you
know if you think about the role that's
a 1984 played in our privacy debates for
50 years where you know the abstract
question of privacy you know if there
were cameras everywhere I would feel
different and some of my activities
would be chilled is a very bloodless
argument but that is an Orwellian notion
imports by reference the entire visceral
experience of reading 1984 although it
takes that the dry skeleton of the
argument and puts blood and flesh and
must
all on that skeleton and makes it very
very literally visceral and maybe reach
different audiences also it's absolutely
one of the issues in the modern age that
different audiences are getting their
information from different places right
and one of the interesting things about
climate change for example is how it's
become this tribal marker especially
within the United States there's a lot
of conservative my understanding is
there's a lot of conservative parties
worldwide who's like well of course the
climate is changing like why would we
deny that but in the u.s. it's become
something where if you're on this side
of other political debates you have to
deny climate change yeah and I think
that the the fragmentation of our
beliefs is important but overrated
compared to the fragmentation of our
epistemology of how we know what to
believe in that in a complicated
technical society we long ago had to put
away the idea that you would just ask a
trusted person what was true and instead
we have trusted processes right that
there are there are reasons that people
of goodwill might disagree about the
technical answer to hard questions like
what should what food preparation
techniques will allow you to eat your
dinner without dropping dead before
breakfast or which pharmaceutical
products are safe to use and under what
circumstances or is the reinforced steel
joist that's holding up the roof over
our head of sufficient strength and
flexibility to keep us all from dying
from the roof falling or the manufacture
of this jumbo jet actually put in the
right seat right it isn't right or you
know is the tailpipe of your car pumping
us so much NO x that it's gonna kill you
all of those things are our questions
that we can't hope to navigate
individually like you even if you had
the media literacy to know which
scientific journals are trustworthy and
which ones aren't and the statistical
literacy to evaluate studies to see
whether they were performed well you
wouldn't have the domain expertise to
then actually look at the technical
particulars of all of those studies to
evaluate them but we have a process
right we have truth-seeking exercises
where independent adjudicators here from
multiple experts
they listen to the competing claims they
explain their reasoning when they come
to a conclusion
they are bound by strict ethical
guidelines about how they can be related
to the parties whose claims they're
hearing and there is a process for
appeal if new facts come to light or if
the process was revealed to have had
flaws right but that process has become
increasingly fraught right if the
ability of truth seeking to actually
look for the truth is now cabined by the
extent to which the truth Gore's a
billionaires ox and so truth seeking has
become something of an auction and that
is really problematic I mean you ret you
alluded to bowing in the 737 max you
know the 737 max was a decision by it by
an expert body that Boeing could
self-regulate certain elements of its
safety features if that was like wrong
on its face right it should have been
obvious that that was wrong the reason
they came to that consent is mattr right
and the reason they came to that
conclusion is because aerospace is super
concentrated and Boeing has been self
regulating for a very long time because
all of the regulators are drawn from its
executive ranks or the ranks of its
direct competitors right who are you
know when there's only five companies
left in an industry all the executives
and each company used to work at the
other ones right so you know it's it's
that they're you really end up with just
one company so you know you look at the
FCC the good FCC Chairman we had under
Obama Tom wheeler it was a Comcast
lobbyist and the bad FCC Chairman we
have under under Trump is a G PI is a
Verizon lawyer right I you know when
truth seeking becomes an auction you are
cast into an epistemological void right
where literally you could die because
you don't know what's true and what
isn't Pharma being a really good example
right people who don't believe in
vaccinations I think are wrong but the
story they tell of why they shouldn't
trust vaccines is right they say the
pharmaceutical industry is super
concentrated
it's run by financialized management
elites who don't care if they kill the
people who take their products and the
regulators are supposed to regulate them
actually let them get away with murder
and you know as exhibit a I would cite
the opioid epidemic right and you know
understanding why claims that
the conclusions that our truth-seeking
exercises have come to about vaccines
are true and the conclusions that they
came to but opioids were false because
the reason we have the opiate epidemic
is not just because of the sackler
simply do Pharma it's because the NIH
and the FDA allowed tainted evidence to
produce guidance about the safety of
opioids that was wrong and and should
have been understood to be wrong right
it wasn't even a particularly good
forgery the majority of it all cited
back to a five sentence letter sent by
Boston University doctor dr. Jick to the
New England Journal Medicine in the
1980s where he observed in a qualitative
but not quantitative way that the
patients in his hospital we're not
becoming addicted to opioids been used
for pain relief at the rate predicted by
the literature as it existed and it was
literally just a letter not a study it
became the most cited thing that the New
England Journal of Medicine ever
published they call it the five most
consequential sentences in the history
of medicine it should have been obvious
right you should have been obvious to
anyone who was whose job it was to keep
the pharmaceutical companies honest that
this was not about what was healthy or
safe it was about what was profitable
and so you can't really fully fault
vaccine denial because the shape of the
vaccine conspiracy the alleged vaccine
conspiracy is the shape of a real
conspiracy yeah the opioid can spear and
sometimes there are conspiracies right
yeah increasingly there are conspiracies
right so you know there's a widespread
belief among some african-americans that
in Katrina the reason that black
parishes were flooded was that the
levees were dynamited to spare the white
neighborhoods I I don't think that
happened it seems a it seems that that
didn't happen
however in the 50s in Tupelo Mississippi
they dynamited the levees to flood the
black neighborhoods and spare the white
neighborhoods and so in the absence of
confirming or disconfirming evidence
that the hypothesis that maybe this
happen you know once as accidents
accident twice as coincidence three
times as enemy
you know that like if it's happened a
bunch of times it's not unreasonable to
think maybe it happened again
you know you scratching you f ologist
you find someone who knows chapter and
verse about real military and aerospace
cover-ups
yeah right now I don't think that area
51 is stuff full of aliens but I do
think that there are military cover-ups
right and so you know what we end up
falling back on rather than does the
truth-seeking exercise think it's true
or not is this heuristic of does someone
who some who says things that have
turned out to be correct
tell me that there is a conspiracy afoot
and if so I guess I'll just trust them
based on whatever they say Donald Trump
tells you the system is rigged the
system is rigged and then when he tells
you that climate change is a Chinese
hoax
he is credible because he was the only
politician and during the debates who
would say the system was rigged and that
part was true
right he was gonna rig it more right but
he wasn't lying about that and you know
I think that this epistemological crisis
our inability to know whether something
is true as opposed to what we believe in
that this more than anything is
responsible for the fragmentation in our
beliefs and we focused too much on the
fire and not nearly enough on the
kindling piled up all around the base of
the tree if you're a frequent podcast
listener it makes sense that you're also
a fan of audiobooks and audible has the
world's largest selection of audiobooks
and audio entertainment including
original content it's just so convenient
right to be able to listen to a book no
matter how short or long when you're
going to work when you're walking when
you're working out when you're doing
other things you can listen to audible
on your mobile device Bluetooth whatever
it is that you like to use and audible
members get more than ever before every
month you can choose one audiobook
regardless of price as well as two
audible originals from a fresh selection
you can also get free updates from the
New York Times The Wall Street Journal
the Washington Post delivered daily to
the app I have four different books that
are available on audible the big picture
was the other one that I read my
I spent a lot of days there in the
studio reading so it would mean a lot to
me if you downloaded the big picture
from audible go to audible.com slash
mindscape or text mindscape to 500 500
that's audible.com slash mindscape or
text mindscape to 5 0 0 - 5 0 0 choose
your one audiobook and - audible
originals absolutely free by using that
code start listening today but where
does it fundamentally come from and what
is the difference between now and fifty
years ago and this is it just because
the ways that we get our information is
different or is no I think it's
monopolies okay right and I think it's I
think it's inequality right I think it
actually has the same root as what's
going on on the internet that you know
if you if you if you want to look at it
through Tom Opik Hetty's lens in the
capital in 21st century you have a
period through most of the world in
which the share of wealth owned by the
richest was very high and the share of
wealth owned by everyone else was very
low there are a couple of events that
ended up rebalancing that temporarily
the French Revolution was one
manumission in America was another one
the majority of wealth on America's
national balance sheet was an enslaved
Africans the conversion of enslaved
Africans in law from assets to humans
wiped a substantial fraction of the
gross national wealth off the books
and since the majority of that wealth
was held in a few hands you ended up
with a much more equal civilization a
much more equal nation one of the most
equal in the history of the world and
that what happens after that is a period
of enormous growth and pluralism it's by
no means perfect I mean reconstruction
Jim Crow are obviously not pluralistic
policies but the policies overall
compared to the pre Civil War policies
are much more pluralistic and inclusive
and that's in part because the rich
people didn't have as much money and so
they couldn't spare as much to affect
policy outcomes and the other thing
Paquette e says is that over time wealth
concentrates that even in fast-growing
dynamic economies everything else being
equal rich people get richer
and he you know has this great parable
where he contrasts the fortunes of Bill
Gates Microsoft founder with liliane
bettencourt the heiress of the the
Loreal fortune richest woman on earth
who's never done a day's work in her
life with Bill Gates investor so after
Bill Gates quit Microsoft II an equally
long career as a financial plumber
moving money around as opposed to making
things that people needed and Bill Gates
fortune over the period in which he
founded this most successful company in
the history of the world grew more
slowly than lily and Bettencourt's
fortune so the new money in liliane
bettencourt bank account over the same
period as someone who did nothing but
owned assets were larger than Bill Gates
his fortune but Bill Gates his fortune
as an investor grew by more than either
right so just being someone who owns
things will always all other things
being equal make you richer even than
people who do things that make all of
our lives better and so over time wealth
begins to concentrate so you have a
bunch of events that make wealth more
equal and then wealth concentrates and
concentrates and one of the things about
concentrated wealth is it's
intrinsically unstable because you can't
follow policy to places that are good
for society and said you have to follow
policy that creates parochial benefit
for rich people and that overtime that
policy debt manifests in political
instability which creates revolutions or
Wars or other kinds of crises or
catastrophes in piketty's view that the
big one was world war two World War one
the interwar period in World War two
which was the largest capital
destruction in the history of the world
because the capital prior to that had
been held in so few hands perforce the
majority capital destroyed belonged to
rich people everything because they were
the only people who had any money and
then you have what the French call the
thirty glorious years date on Gloria's
right that the creation of the welfare
state the most prosperous period in
human history and over time you also
have an accumulation of wealth right the
rich are getting richer by the mid-70s
the share of wealth owned by the top
decile has reached a tipping point and
you start to see you know the projects
that elect Reagan that dismantle
progressive taxation that dismantle
redistributed policies that limit
intergenerational wealth transfer like
like inheritance taxes you start to see
the
dismantling of antitrust protection of
labor protections all of the things that
are pluralistic and janna and generate
public good in favor of private good for
an increasingly small cohort of
increasingly wealthy and powerful people
but how does this lead to the antibac
spawned I'm welding the crea it creates
industries that only have four or five
players okay right that have so much
money that when the FDA is considering
what to do chances are everyone who's
working at the FDA in a decision-making
role used to work for one of those
companies and those companies have a lot
of money to spend lobbying the FDA right
that's the same way you get Network
discrimination policies under Ajit PI it
was one of the most expensive regulatory
adventures in the history of any
industry killing net neutrality right
and and it was only possible because
Comcast had cornered these monopolies in
1880 one of these monopolies where they
divided up America and said we will
serve here and you will serve there and
we won't compete with each other we'll
make more money by charging more for
delivering less and systematically under
under investing in infrastructure
pocketing money intended for for
infrastructure build out in rural places
and underserved places without
delivering that either and we will use
some of that surplus capital most of it
will go to our shareholders right but
we'll use some of that surplus capital
to continue to lobby for even more
relaxed rules that benefit us more at
the public expense that that at its core
is just true seeking exercises auction
right that that's what it means to
influence policy for parochial rather
than public benefit is to turn the
truth-seeking exercise into an option so
a really good example of this that makes
it super obvious that truth-seeking can
become auctions is in West Virginia we
think of West Virginia's coal country
it's actually chemical processing
country it's the major industry there's
chemical processing and because of
monopolization one company is larger
than all the rest put together and
that's Dow Chemicals so Dow in the
chemical industry lobbies West
Virginians Dow lobbying them so Dallas
are at the chemical industries lobby
group lobbied the state of West Virginia
for variances in the national limits on
how much toxic runoff from chemical
processing could enter the drinking
water supply and they argued that the
national levels were too restrictive and
that West Virginia could have less
strict --iv rules and they they argued
for that on the basis that the national
levels were set based on the national
BMI and that West Virginians are so much
fatter that the poison was ignore dilute
in our tissues and that also West
Virginians hardly drink water right this
was their basis for asserting this now
like you're a California you remember
before we had recreational marijuana we
had medical marijuana and in theory you
can only get medical marijuana if you
had a condition that demanded but in
practice there was a box on the form
that you were supposed to write
depression or trouble sleeping or
glaucoma I promise and then they would
hand you the medical marijuana card the
the actions of Dow Chemical in their
Lobby in West Virginia are the actions
of a company that knows that they don't
need a good reason they just need a
reason right they literally could have
written you know my daughter is helping
with her math homework last night one of
the questions was like evaluate whether
you know y equals x squared would
produce this point on on a line and
explain your reasoning and she said no
because I said so you know if it is that
it is the action of a firm that
understands that in truth seeking
exercises all they need is to say
because I said so and that is reason
enough so but just to make it super
duper clear so in in one part of the
story the monopoly power leads to
corporations or interests that want to
promulgate a line of truth and but
there's there's also a reaction against
it because you don't know who to believe
anymore and sure that's why so there's
no big corporation that is promoting an
Tyvek speak um zan epistemological II
respectable position if you share leave
anything you hear yeah it becomes so
what we have to fall back on is someone
who sounds trustworthy rather than a
process that is that is legitimate and
someone who sounds trustworthy can be
someone who tells you a true thing and
then says a bunch of false things you
know I once had a meeting with this guy
David Allen who wrote this great
productivity book called getting things
done really good book and and I read it
and it helped me get a lot more things
done it's you know how to use cool
checklist yeah to manage your time I
said where did you get the core method
how did you develop it and he said oh
well I took all the best stuff from
Scientology because when they make you a
Scientologist the first thing they do is
to
to a bunch of stuff that works and then
they start sucking money out of your
wallet right um you know con artists
they call this putting someone on the
send right so when you fall under the
spell of a con artist the first thing
you do is pay you right they get you to
they get you to like participate in a
scam where you win and they say ah let's
let's now that you see that the scam
works we're gonna put you on the scent
go home cash out your kids college fund
get a second mortgage and empty your
401k and come back we'll do it again
right so this is putting you on the
scent right Donald J Trump says the
system is rigged and you go like ha kind
of Israel it is rigged
yeah and then he puts you on the Senate
he says climate changes of Chinese hoax
and it's all immigrants fault and you
know like the fact that he's told you
one true thing makes the other things
more credible it's like Douglas Adams in
the towel right if you're and the
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy if you
have a towel people will go gosh if he's
got a towel he must be really prepared
and then if you say well I've lost my
toothbrush and my soap and my shampoo
and my backpack and my Rail Pass they'll
give you everything else because you've
got the towel you have that credibility
so is there a strategy at the individual
level for dealing with this world we're
in where it's harder to know who to
trust you know I I think that ultimately
that is the great crisis right that that
without that it is very hard to know
what to do and when to trust someone and
you know I can't evaluate all the truth
claims that I need to to get on the
right side of in order to survive and
thrive right to know whether or not the
index fund that my 401k is in is is
being run by grifters and to know
whether or not the the common core
curriculum that my daughter is going
through is going to prepare adequately
for life all those things like I can't
musical here with the medical care yeah
all of that stuff you know I like where
I'm a Canadian and so medical insurance
just freaks me out and when we got
medical coverage here we let my wife's
employer talk us into getting a health
savings account she turns out to be the
biggest in the world right and I was
like the way you described it sounds
reasonable and when I google it I get a
bunch of contradictory things all I know
is that last year we put thousands of
dollars into this thing that they then
clawed back on January 1 like what do
you mean I was
saving that in case I needed a hip
replacement you know so uh the the
individual can do very little except
band together with other individuals to
lobby for structural changes you know we
can model by as best as we can in the
same way you know I some I have
colleagues in the kind of digital Human
Rights world who talk about cryptography
as a way of defending human rights right
they said well if you can keep secrets
from powerful states then you can you
know keep them from knowing who you are
and what you do and using that to punish
you and there's a an element of truth to
that but defenders have a harder time
than attackers right eventually you will
make a mistake right the the state that
wants to surveil you can afford to have
three shifts of agents watching
everything you do whereas when you get
to our eight and you've got sand in your
eyes and you you're seeing double and
you're tired and angry and you're making
dumb mistakes you don't get to rotate
another you on to make sure that you
never put you know recycle a password or
download a firmware blob without
double-checking the the hash of it or
you know any of the other things that
you need to do to have perfect
operational security so that for me the
role of cryptography is not to create a
kind of stable demi-monde
that lives alongside an unaccountable
illegitimate state it's to create a kind
of temporary shelter that we can hide
under while we organize to make the
state more accountable and legitimate
that you know ultimately you know all of
us are vulnerable to what's called
rubber-hose cryptanalysis right your
cipher may be so strong that all the
computers in the universe you know every
hydrogen atom in the universe yeah you
know turn into a computer guessing what
your password is your passphrase is
would run out of universe before you ran
out of passphrase combinations but if
someone can tie you to a chair and hit
you with a rubber hose until you tell
them the passphrase it doesn't matter
right so what you need is not just
cryptography but you need the rule of
law you need for it to be illegal for
your government to kidnap you and tie
you to a chair and hit you with a rubber
hose now cryptography can help you
defend yourself
legitimate state to organize to make
that law a reality but not forever right
and so really there is no substitute for
the legal code that sits alongside the
technological code and does that help
also I mean it's not only that I want to
be right and it's difficult to know who
to trust but I want other people to be
right - and I don't necessarily trust
that the typical median voter for
example is trying that hard even to be
right I mean what are the systemic
strategies we can use just to share
truths more widely throughout our
society so I I would disagree with that
characterization I mean there are some
people who you know are on the sidelines
of some of these questions right people
who like don't feel strongly one way or
another about vaccines but they do what
the doctor tells them but you will you
will be hard-pressed to find a casual
anti-vaxxer right anti-vaxxers aren't
anti-vaxxers because they don't care
about the truth anti-vaxxers to harden
that position requires really deep
effort right a lot more energy than most
of us put into most of the technical
aspects of our lives right to be an
auntie vac so if you think about
vaccines it's like just one of the many
health interventions that are made in
your life over the course of your life
to be really into it I mean it's nerdy
right it's like being really really
really into like you know differential
transmissions or something right like
not just into cars yeah right but into
like a really specific kind of spark
plug right and so it's not that those
people don't care about the truth it's
that they're wrong yeah and the method
by which they determine the truth is
flawed which is why they're wrong
but they're it's not that they are they
lack fervor to discover the truth so
giving them better ways to figure out
what the truth is is the biggest part of
creating legitimate system yeah that we
can point out in trust right
I mean you know sometimes people will
get on about the 50s and it's
complacency and they are the time in
which everyone trusted their government
even as their government was you know
engaged in dirty wars and in in South
Asia or you know post post-war
reconstruction colonialism in the
Pacific Rim or whatever but but
the legitimacy of the state is a very
important asset for a functional society
right that that illegitimate states
create low trust societies that are
polarized and that are incoherent and
how they arrive at the truth I mean you
know that we hear a lot about Russian
interference and I think that it's
overstated if for no other reason than
if a basket-case failed state like
Russia can tip us over into a chaotic
world like the one we live in then our
world was more fragile than it should
have been right the state was more
fragile than it should have been but one
thing that guides the the oligarchic
movement in Russia is a media strategy
that is centered around making it hard
to know what the truth is right not just
about pushing an alternate line of truth
but to making me but to making the truth
itself seem unattainable so you know
Putin's media strategist cheerfully
admits that some of the opposition
groups and in Russia are ones that he's
secretly funding and and that he's
planted provocateur is always more
confrontation but he won't tell you
which ones yeah you know this is why it
is worrisome to think that maybe black
lives matters group on Facebook on
Facebook some of them were were not
legitimate or were you know insincere
whatever it is Facebook calls them
because it means that everybody has to
wonder whether or not the group that
there is one legit yes legit right it's
very destabilizing to our power of
collective action and so having a
legitimate state a state that is
accountable and transparent and
legitimate and pluralistic is theirs
there's no substitute for it and once
you have that state and then you start
to to abuse it you can coast for a while
but eventually a crisis builds up and
that's where we've arrived at well I
like to end we're reaching the end of
our time here I like to end on an
optimistic note there are not succeeding
right now to mistake
for optimistic notes so there's a
copyright scholar called James Boyle who
runs the Duke Center for the public
domain with Jennifer Jenkins and Jamie
wrote a book called the public domain
where he talks about information
politics by means of the metaphor of
environmental politics and he says that
before the term ecology was coined and
came into widespread use you had people
who cared about whales and you liked
people who cared about fresh air and you
had people who cared about tailpipe
emissions you have people who cared
about the ozone layer but they didn't
think of themselves as all being part of
one fight they thought of these as each
of them as separate fights and the term
ecology welded them together into a
movement it it made every one of those
causes aspects of the same fight that
you know we don't even have another way
to describe it except to call it an
ecological fight and that is what is
mobilizing millions of people in the
streets right that the people who care
about climate change some of them care
about it because they care about
drinking water and some of them care
about it because they care about natural
habitats and so on and so on but they're
all together because they all agree that
these are facets of the same struggle
well inequality and monopolies and
corruption have produced constituents
from so many different domains for a
pluralistic reform so there's one
company that makes all the eyewear
you've ever heard of its called
luxottica they bought every single
eyewear brand first they bought all the
major retailer sunglass hut and Sears
Optical and Target optical and
LensCrafters and then they refused to
carry any eyewear brand that wouldn't
sell to them until they drove them to
their knees and picked them up for
pennies and literally if you've if
you've got any of the major I wear
brands
it's luxottica and if you bought them at
any major retailers it's luxottica and
if your lenses came from SLR which is
the largest lens manufacturer in the
world that came from luxottica and if
you're unsure as I'm ed which is largest
insurer in America it's also luxottica
and they've raised prices a thousand
percent in ten years right and so there
are a bunch of people who wear glasses
who care about pluralism and monopolies
but there used to be thirty wrestling
leagues and now there's one and it's
owned by this billionaire Trump donor
called Vince McMahon he reclassified all
the wrestlers as contractors took away
their healthcare they're dropping dead
in their 50s
GoFundMe is full of famous wrestlers
begging their fans for money to pay
their medical bills right so if you're a
wrestling fan you're with the eyewear
people now there are three talent
agencies left in Hollywood and all of
the screenwriters fired all of their
agents because the talent agencies are
now all owned by private equity funds
and those private equity funds have
decided that to increase their return on
investment that the agencies are going
to start doing what's called packaging
where they package a writer and a
director and a whatever and they collect
a fee from the studio for that package
and in exchange they agree to take less
money for each of their clients and so
every screenwriter in Hollywood is there
for you to fight for wrestlers and
eyewear and then there's technologists
who care about the web only having five
giant websites filled with screen shots
from the other four and there's people
who work in the energy sector and
there's people who work in finance right
so that the whistleblowers who got fired
for refusing to help Wells Fargo to
fraud their customers and then there's
the two million customers that Wells
Fargo defrauded right so over and over
again right this is the 11th anniversary
of the bailout right everyone who's
who's pissed off because their house was
stolen by a mortgage issuer who used
robo-signing
to forge the documents needed to steal
their house is there for you on this
corruption fight they just don't know it
so we are on the verge of going from
denial to nihilism right of going of
that peak denial we were on the verge of
having a potential mass movement and our
job is going from convincing people that
there's a problem to convince them that
it's not too late to do something about
it and our political discourse is
shifting so fast right these issues are
bubbling up in all the major parties the
right wing has suddenly discovered
antitrust because for years and years
they're ok with it because their pay
masters were getting rich from it and
then one day they woke up and they
realize that a 5 tech executives decided
they didn't like them that they
disappeared from the internet and thus
from our public discourse and all of a
sudden tucker carlson is sounding like
Brandeis right yeah and so you know I'm
not saying first they came for the Nazis
and I did nothing cuz I wasn't a Nazi
and then they came to me I think first
they came for the trans activist and
then they came for the pipeline activist
and then they came for the sex workers
and then they came for you know all
kinds of people that I cared about and
we
nothing now they finally came for the
Nazis right and Tucker Carlson wants to
do something maybe we can get something
done right and my colleague a tff
gillian york is the person who tipped me
off to this and she's so right about it
and so we are really on the verge of a
moment in which everybody figures out
that this is the issue of our day that
climate change denial and vaccine denial
and bridges falling down and
infrastructure under investment and you
know the racist policies that have
created the refugee crises in Central
America that all of these are aspects of
corruption and that we're all on the
same side when it comes to fighting
corruption except for a tiny minority of
billionaires who are themselves
increasingly of the opinion that they
need to find expensive boltholes to hide
in when people start building
guillotines on their lawn I like it's an
interesting perspective because you know
when you try to cast the political
battle as you know soak the rich and
decrease inequality there's people who
think well maybe I will be rich someday
but if you say break up monopolies and
decrease corruption very few people
think of themselves as future monopolist
yeah that's right and you know yes
temporarily embarrassed millionaires
have always been a problem in American
politics you know as as have you know
what the left called bootlickers
sometimes you know the people who are
like well there are social betters you
know we should just let Elon Musk get on
with it because iron man was the
greatest you know and but but yeah
nobody nobody idolizes monopolists yeah
except for you know Peter Thiel right
who who will tell you that monopolies
are efficient because competition just
wastes so much resource yeah you know
why can't we just have our wise
philosopher Kings later I was just gonna
say Plato said the same thing about
democracy anyway plenty to think about
cory doctorow thanks so much for being
on the podcast my pleasure thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]